deux ans et demi après sa réélection
françois de ligne et jette l'épongé le
maire ps de guyancourt n'a donné pour
expliquer sa démission d'autres raisons
que celles de passer le relais à temps
il ya une décision de passage de relais
et pourquoi maintenant
parce que avec d'état d'esprit que
j'indiquais c'est à dire celui d'une
préparation de l'avenir
je sais que c'est le bon moment parce
qu'on va pouvoir travailler en
continuité
l'ancien instituteur mer depuis 2002
répète ainsi l'histoire
son prédécesseur à la mairie des
guyancourt roland nadeau c'était en
effet lui aussi démis de ses fonctions
en cours de mandat c'est un message au
sud de poursuites puisque françois de
ligne continue
je reste encore un petit peu ici je
prends un peu de chance la vie ma ville
c'est ma ville de son côté l'opposition
havok l'usure dont se serait plaint en
privé françois de lignées mais aussi
l'existence de conflits internes à sa
majorité
guyancourt pour tous des propos que
l'intéressé dément
chez lui là quelqu'un de l'opposition
parlant d' usure
bon on verra parce que moi je serai dans
le conseil jusqu'à 2020 il verra si si
on a une équipe usée
élu depuis 1989 françois des lignes et a
gagné la réputation d'homme accessible
grâce notamment à son dispositif
allô monsieur le maire mais c'est
surtout son bilan économique que l'on
retiendra
surfant sur l'attractivité de son
territoire il a su convaincre de grandes
entreprises d'y investir
nous sommes une ville qui atteint sa
maturité qui est encore en dynamique et
qu'à un projet qui placera demain but en
cours comme étant toujours la locomotive
même pas de saint quentin en yvelines
plus largement du bassin de vie c'est
marie-christine le tarnec 60 ans
première adjointe en charge de
l'éducation de la jeunesse et des
finances qui devrait lui succéder avant
la fin de l'année une passation de
pouvoir bien orchestrée qui permettent à
l'équipe municipale de se projeter
au-delà de 2020 mais une question
subsiste sera ce suffisant pour barrer
le passage à la droite